Hello. This is
Six Minute English
from
BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Have you ever had a horrible boss,
not been paid enough
or simply got tired of doing the same
old boring jobs?
I love presenting Six Minute
English, of course, but
some of my previous jobs
have been pretty awful, Neil.
When I waitressed in cafes,
I was on my feet ten hours a day.
It was exhausting!
Most people have
had bad work experiences
at one time or another.
Maybe a job
that was boring, badly paid
or just working too much
and getting burned out –
lacking energy or enthusiasm
because of working too hard.
But does it have
to be like this?
Since most of our waking
day is spent at work,
how can we make sure
our job doesn't make us unhappy?
That's what we'll be discussing
in this programme
and, as usual,
we'll be learning
some useful new
vocabulary as well.
Sounds good,
Beth, but first
I have a question for you.
The worst job
I ever had was the summer
I spent working as a portable
toilet cleaner at music festivals.
But, according to a recent survey
by Forbes Magazine,
what was voted the
worst job in the UK? Was it:
A. a call centre worker?
B. a bartender? or
C. a traffic warden?
I think the answer might be
a call centre worker.
OK, Beth. I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
Now, it's interesting that survey
was carried out in the UK
because being unhappy
at work could be related
to the British working culture which
emphasises working at a fast pace.
Here's Damian Grimshaw,
a professor of Employment
Studies at King's College London
speaking with BBC
Radio 4 programme, Analysis.
Really it's all about pace,
cost efficiencies, meeting targets
and deadlines. So, this is why,
when people do surveys of
what we call 'work intensity',
so how hard you work
are you driven on pace?, is there a
supervisor breathing down your neck?,
we score really badly compared
to European countries.
Compared to some European countries
British workers have to meet more
targets and deadlines – a time or date
by which a particular job must be
finished. The pressure to
work quickly means you might have
your boss breathing down your neck –
an idiom meaning that
someone is watching you very closely
and checking everything you do –
not a nice feeling to have at work.
That's right. A good job is
about more than pay and conditions.
It's one that uses your talents
and gives you some choice
over how and when you work.
In 2022, Britain's biggest employer,
the National Health Service, or NHS,
lost more than 15,000 nurses,
many quitting because of the long
and inflexible working hours.
Another sector
with long working hours is
the construction industry. Low paid,
dirty and physically demanding
construction workers also risk high
levels of work-related injury.
Here, Emma Stewart, co-founder
of social business,
Time Wise, tells BBC's
Radio 4 programme, Analysis,
about her trial project to help
builders enjoy their jobs more.
In the work that
we've done within the
construction industry,
we have trialled
what we would call
an output-based way of working,
which means we shift away
from the sense of presenteeism,
this sense of: you
are paid by the day,
you are on site
from seven in the morning
until the last person leaves,
maybe seven in the evening...
to a task-based way of working, which
means you're going to do five tasks
over the course of this day, when
you've done those tasks,
and you've done them well,
you can go home,
but we will still pay you the
same amount for the day.
They were able to deliver the
projects that we worked on with them
on time, on budget,
but, critically, the
feedback from workers was
that work-life balance scores doubled
and they were able to reduce the amount
of overtime that they did.
It's a win-win.
Emma describes
the current working
patterns using the word presenteeism –
staying at work longer than usual
or going to work when you're ill
to show that you work hard,
but this isn't an
effective way to work.
Emma thinks a task-based approach is
better both at getting the job done
and for improving work-life balance –
the amount of time you spend at work,
compared with the amount of time
you spend relaxing with your family
and doing things you enjoy.
In other words,
flexible working
is a win-win – a situation
that's good for everyone involved.
Maybe more flexible working
would help some of the jobs
I mentioned earlier
in my question, Beth.
According to a
recent Forbes magazine survey,
what was voted the worst job
in the UK?
I guessed it was a job
I've done myself –
working in a call centre.
That was... the correct answer!
Although I think my summer job
cleaning toilets was even worse.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned from this programme,
starting with burnout – lack
of energy or enthusiasm
because of working too hard.
A deadline is the time
by which a particular job
must be done.
If someone is breathing down your
neck, they're watching you very closely
and checking everything you do.
Presenteeism means staying
at work longer than usual to show
your employer that you work hard
and are important to them.
Work-life balance
is the amount of time
you spend doing your job
compared with the amount of time
you spend doing things you enjoy.
And finally, a win-win
is a situation or result
that is good for everyone.
Once again,
our six minutes are up.
Join us again next time,
but for now,
get back to work!
Goodbye. Bye.